people have always asked me kind of like
where I'm from what my race is and I was
not totally sure
[Music]
I identify as mixed white black and
Native American african-american but my
mom would say you're black but you're
also white I didn't understand what that
meant other something different not
quite black not quite white I identify
as mixed race but I don't think the
world sees me as mixed race 32% Northern
European 28% Mediterranean 21%
sub-saharan African 14% Southwest Asian
[Music]
very they all look like they're related
to me this looks like my family like
literally you have how familiar they
feel
honestly
[Music]
I have no idea why this makes me
emotional
do
I mean there's tremendous diversity and
how we look but yet I could see that I
could be related to any one of them the
one where did I get the most is unique
and that's what all these people sorta
have in common my dad used to joke and
say uh your black Irish Oh your black
Irish and guess what I'm like oh we have
a lot more in common than we have
differences one person is not just one
race
[Music]
you